[Music]
I hope you had a lousy time at that camp
because you are not going back I missed
you too much the movie The Parent Trap
shows how coming home from camp can be
just as emotional for parents as it is
for kids
many American parents go through this
rite of passage every summer around 15
million kids attend camp each year in
the United States and John Dickerson is
one of those parents he is off this week
catching up with his own kids who just
returned from where camp and this
morning's reporters notebook John
explores the defining experiences and
lessons for both children and their
parents when kids go to camp for most of
the summer my interaction with my
children has been with pictures of them
on my phone their way at summer camp
that proving ground of children and
parents
child psychologist Michael Thompson in
his book on kids and campsites a survey
adults were asked what is your happiest
childhood memory more than 80 percent
said it was a time when they were not
with their parents that was certainly
true of me at camp and I'm happy I
survived most of those experiences when
parents aren't around kids fully
experience things mom and dad aren't
looking over their shoulder and there
are no dumb questions this encourages
risk-taking and discovery and that's the
stuff of identity we see glimpses of
this genuine identity when we watch our
kids and they don't know we're watching
or when we eavesdrop and hear them
making claims and testing theories and
that's what we want as parents for our
kids that they create identities that
can survive in the world but then this
creates a problem for the parents who
show up at the end of the summer with
thousands of questions about that
experience they saw their kids doing
when they smoothed out their picture on
the camp's website our natural desire to
interrogate our children risks ruining
the purity of those experiences they've
had without us
this is about more than summer escapades
this is the essential challenge of
parenthood if we want our kids to be
independent we have to teach them to
leave us it gets harder when they get
older when they're younger we can take
our hand off the back of the bicycle but
when they get older to really help them
on their journey though we may want to
ride with them we have to let them ride
alone it's so hard though I know my
daughter Grace is his mom we're like
little birds we're gonna fly away soon
yes go and then no you have plenty of
time oh I still so young you're a little
baby but they grow up so fast
but then wait till they go off to
college then go for good very nice John
very nice